[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul
aka the guy who's a bigger
disappointment than ccxp
yesterday in a teaser that lasted longer
than my first time with a woman
warner brothers showed off a glimpse of
godzilla and kong doing what they do
best
the first look trailer had both the
titans rushing towards each other
and now on the surface there's very
little to take from this
there's actually a lot going on now
before we get into the breakdown i have
to say that there will be some spoilers
here in regards to the film
we do have some plot leaks and whilst
these can't be verified until we see the
film for ourselves
we will be talking about what reportedly
leads up to this moment
anyway without the way thank you for
clicking this now let's get into the
breakdown
okay so the footage for the scene takes
place roughly over two seconds
but we've done what we normally do and
over analyze the entire thing
to let you know what's going on because
we have no life
now the first thing that we see is
godzilla swimming towards the camera
this is something that we've seen a
hundred times before in the movies
but it actually holds special
significance this time around
as it's used to signify the domains of
the pair
in the film we're going to discover that
a shady organization called apex have
actually been looking for a way to
destroy the titans
and using the brain of one of the
ghidorah heads they've built
mechagodzilla
this was teased at the end of the prior
entry and apparently they've coupled
this with the skeleton of the gajira
that was found in order to build the
massive machine monster
this titan killer will wipe them all off
the face of the earth
and thus they're basically trying to get
kong and godzilla to face off against
each other
so that they have an easier time
defeating the survivor now monarch
obviously want to stop this
and they go searching for both godzilla
and kong
as we learned in king of the monsters
godzilla's home is atlantis
and thus the beast is very much seen as
the ruler of the ocean
which is symbolized by the water that we
first see him in here
this idea of the ocean was also shown in
the logo itself
as godzilla's name is in blue whereas
kongs is in
orange this has been carried across from
the old one directly into the new one
so clearly something is going on with it
now orange is also a color that has a
special meaning
and even the first sukkah kong that we
have has an almost sunset feel to it
as typically this is the color that we
associate with the character
skull island had an amazing use of
orange pretty much across the board
and this actually subtly nods to what's
going on with them
as we've discussed godzilla is pretty
much the king of the ocean
but kong is seen as the ruler of the
earth in the film it will be revealed
that the hollow earth has a wealth of
caverns and connecting tunnels that will
reach back to skull island
and through these the titans will have
traveled to find safety
in the movie we'll discover that kong
resides over them and will be called the
ruler of the natural earth
now in regards to the end of the film
apparently the pair fight to the point
that they're both heavily damaged
and their mecha godzilla is brought in
to kill them as apex don't want to lose
this opportunity
the fight ends with them taking down the
machine and then they go back to their
own domains
in order to oversee them kong becomes
the king of the hollow earth
which is when he finally gets a title
king kong which so far
has been missing but apparently he's
gonna get it here
godzilla remains as king of the monsters
and becomes
its guardian so again we have this idea
of the opposing side symbolized in the
color that tends to be shown with them
and it will likely be laced throughout
the movie and be the thing that we
associate with the characters
now the kong scene also has a lot going
on in it
the character is actually wearing a
color and there are a lot of questions
surrounding
why it's there and what it's for i think
the answer actually shows that the
creative team
are looking to the past appearances of
kong in cinema in order to pay homage to
what's come before
callers have long been associated with
kong and in the past whenever he's
appeared in a film outside of skull
island
the humans have typically captured him
put him in restraints and use these to
transport him
the idea of the character being in
chains and restraints is something that
we've seen lays throughout his many
appearances
even going so far back as the 1930s film
so this moment does carry a lot with it
now according to the leaks
monarch investigates skull island and
they discover not only kong but the
rituals that have been performed around
him turns out that both kong godzilla
come from bloodlines that have gone to
war with one another in the past
and this has been marked in cave
paintings which tell a story
but also prophesies the upcoming battle
between the pair
the islanders all worship kong is a god
and thus in order to help him
they build a giant axe which eventually
gets one of godzilla's spikes put into
it
spikes is that is that the word look i'm
writing this at 6am after staying up all
night to watch
absolutely nothing at ccxp so don't hate
the lad yeah the thumbs up buttons right
there anyway
kong is eventually captured and then
transported away from the island
which apparently is where this battle
happens finn's
fins it was wasn't it anyway the pair
can sense each other and we discover
that kong is
actually the only titan that refuses to
fall under the rule of godzilla
as he sees himself as the true leader
thus
him being taken away from his home and
bumping into the guy he hates
it just ruins your day doesn't it like
you're at work
you spill coffee on yourself so it looks
like you've wet yourself in front of
brenda
who you've been trying to pull for the
last six months and then gary
gary from accounting comes up and you
just hate the lad
it's like that with kong and he's
absolutely raging
and thus he escapes his confines and
that is why
we still see the shackles around him
hopefully that didn't ruin your day that
story now
the eagle-eyed viewers of you may also
notice navy vessels in the background
and to the side this is because the pair
actually go
toe-to-toe on a battleship during the
film and this was actually shown in a
leaked image before the fight was
confirmed in the official marketing
by showing the two duking it out one by
one so this fight scene is definitely
going down
at the moment that we see in this teaser
and because of this setup we can assume
that kong is on the boats being
transported away
which is when godzilla arrives by sea
and the two fighted out both on the
boats and in water
it's gonna be a big battle and i'm
actually glad that we're getting a fight
in broad daylight
as typically these things tend to be
done either at night in a storm
or at night during a rain or in a rain
storm
anyway they're they're really bringing
the big guns out here by the looks of it
and i'm guessing that this is the first
showdown between the pair before they go
head-to-head at the end of the movie
kong will likely be without his axe at
this point
and because godzilla has the water
around him and can probably pull the
character into it
i think it's really gonna be a very
one-sided fight
we have no idea how this comes to a
close as
that was never part of the plot leaks
but i really can't see kong winning
and it's likely that the humans are
gonna have to step in and try and stop
the battle
they'll probably get annihilated either
way but i shouldn't be such suckers then
should you anyway that's how you turn
two seconds of footage into an eight
minute video
and obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts on the first look and if
there's anything we missed
make sure you comment below and let me
know and if you enjoyed this video
please drop a thumbs up
and make sure you check out our full
plot leak breakdown if you want to know
more of the ins and outs of the movie we
also did an initial reaction to the
footage
so if you want to see my face and me
throwing my hands in the air then that's
that's probably the best place for it
don't forget we're giving away three
copies of the lord of the rings 4k box
set and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below
the winner is going to be chosen at
random on the 30th of december
so make sure you get involved if you
want to support the channel and get to
see contents early
then please consider clicking the join
button below you can also come chat just
under discord server linked in the
description or heavy spoilers on twitter
thanks for making it until the end of
the video you being the best i've been
poor i'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you